حاجز الخوف انكسر بالفعل والايرانيون
ليسوا بحاله بحث عن اسباب للتظاهر
فالاف الاسباب تبقيهم في الشارع وتملا
صفحات الدعوات الاحتجاجات اخرى بينها مقتل
اطفال ونساء وذكر انتفاضه نوفمبر عام 2019
[تصفيق]
مراسم تشييع الجنازات في المدن الايرانيه
تحولت لمظاهرات تتقدمها شعارات تخطت الموت
للديكتاتور لتاكيد ان هذا العام هو عام
الدام وسقوط المرشد كذلك التي سيرها اهالي
بركان وسندج خلال جنازه اثنين من قتلاهم
الذين سقطوا برصاص قوه الامن لكن السلطات
تستبق هذه المسيرات الاحتجاجيه باجراءاتنا
باتت شبه اعتياديه لمنع تاجيج الشارع حيث
اغلقت طرق المؤديه الى مكان دفن التجمان
قالبور احد يقتل حمله القمع التي نفذتها
السلطات الايرانيه عام 2019
كما اعتقلت اشخاصا كانوا يخططون للمشاركه
في مراسم احياء الذكر بينهم افراد عائلتي
تجمعنا وضبطت هواتفهم لتنشر بالنيابه عنهم
قصصا تفيد بالغاء المراسم السنويه وفقه
ايران الانترنت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضمه هذه الاحتياجات المتواصله منذ شهرين
تقريبا لم يعد يرويه هتاف او احراق اطارات
ومراكز الشرطه فتركيز المتظاهرين تحول الى
الرموز من اشخاص واماكن حيث اقدم على
اضرام النار في بيت الخميني بمسقط راسه
جنوبي العاصمه طهران والذي قيل انه تحول
الى متحف رغم نفي الاعلام الرسميه
كما اشتعلت النيران بجزء من مبنى حوزه قوم
شمالي البلاد
نبض جديد يحركه وجع دفين يضاف يوميا الى
الشارع الايرانيه فقائمه المدن المنتفضه
في تزايد ولكل سببه